he's sean casey former major league
baseball all-star
mlb network analyst three-time all-star
wearing a smedium here
he's a member of the cincinnati reds
hall of fame what are you doing with the
t-shirt there
i'm just so jacked i mean that you know
what i mean
i don't know it's an it's an xl what
does it look like it's medium
it does give me give me a double gun
give me
both both barrels barrels double barrels
have you been tested any lately sean
well you know what dad i thought i'd get
in shape after i
you are still as slow as you were when
you played right i'm slower than i was
and in better shape
it's just crazy it's crazy all right uh
help me understand major league baseball
it feels like anything that's said at
the home office is linked to the media
here there's no secrets here with major
league baseball
so what do you think is the best case
scenario here for major league baseball
wow yeah you're right i don't think
there are any secrets seems like there's
no secrets anymore in life
you know i mean but uh you know i think
the best case scenario is hopefully
uh you know baseball you know that they
they find a way to maybe get some games
this year i just
i just feel like it would be great for
everybody but i do understand both sides
dan obviously coming from the players
point of view but
i do know i do know rob manfred is is
one of the smartest guys out there
tony bettini who's right next to him you
know those guys that are that are
running baseball are
are are so smart they'll leave no stone
unturned tony clark over there with with
the lawyers that they have with the
union with the players
you know trying to figure this out i do
know that
you know they will they will they will
try and come to a conclusion
that's good for everybody that's good
for the fans of baseball
that's good for the players and the
owners and we're just an uncharted
territory so
some of the things that maybe you know
flew in the past maybe won't now
it's just some of the some of the things
that the players have to do too
to be able to go and play i think they
definitely need to be evaluated but i
think that
that both sides will figure it out
hopefully would you play baseball
if you were still on a roster
you're asking me personally yeah yes
yes i would i'm just trying to
understand
you know the risk with this obviously
the rewards and then you hear blake
snell
of uh the rays saying i it's not enough
money for me to come back and play
can you see the haves and the have-nots
that
you know are big big ticket item guys
not going to come back or you know the
guys who have
less money and as much to like the
league minimum
like yeah can you see where one or the
other is going to say
it's not worth me coming back i can see
you know
both side both pointed points of view
there's i i think one thing with
you know when you think about mike trout
talking about he's about to have a kid
and and you know what if he's
quarantined and you know those kind of
things
those are real things you know and
obviously you know dan over the years
with
with the money back and forth i mean
obviously you know
both sides are going to fight what they
would for for their rights which is
that's what it should be and i think
that's that's fair
um but i do think you know player safety
and and stuff like that with families
and
all that you know definitely comes into
account um but i think the teams will
get together and figure out you know
what's best for the what's best for each
team but i do understand
the point of view of of guys that uh you
know safety for their families and stuff
because i
no one knows just no one knows but i do
think what they say there's going to be
10 000 tests a week
in that and that each each player you
know and if you do get it you will be
quarantined and
so i don't know you know they're trying
to do the best they can with what they
have yeah but they're talking about
you're not allowed to spit
and what happens you're a first baseman
are you holding somebody on first base
and then
you can't have social distancing at
first base john
well i that's crazy i was just uh
talking to somebody this morning about
that
and it reminded me of the story i think
i might even told it on on your show at
one point when you know
social distancing so what happens does
the guy get his his
fi his uh four foot five foot lead off
and then
are you allowed to pick over and i i
still remember i remember i was social
distancing with henry rodriguez my first
year in the big leagues when
you know back in the day when you know
oh henry when he would homer in montreal
i throw those oh henry bars in the field
and i remember him getting off first and
i was like my second week in the big
leagues i'm all excited and
we're social distancing he's about six
feet away and i say to him
hey henry i really love it when they
throw those oh henry bars onto the field
and he turned to me and said hey thanks
a lot man and right when he turned ron
velone step over poop
pick up picked over i caught and i said
oh man i'm my bad
i had no idea i had no idea he was going
to pick over
i thought we were just social i thought
we were just social disciplined 22 years
early
[Laughter]
this it just there's a lot of questions
when they say you can't spit
i i don't can guys do that
i don't know have you ever been into a
big league dugout after the game when
you look down he looks it looks like a
murder scene you're like what happened
here
there's dip spit there's sunflower seed
spit there's freaking spit everywhere
like
you gotta be kidding me like we need a
dna test to see what just happened here
so i can't imagine big leaguers could go
a whole game not spit
imagine when they say you can't adjust
yourself either i mean
there's so much there's so much to
unpack here but that's going to be a
tough one
you adjust yourself twice already during
this interview here
exactly i'm just in my shirt you got me
you're in my head about this medium
comment
i'm an absolute mess right now uh you
got a picture behind you is that
doc gooden and strawberry and
is mike tyson oh yeah mike tyson
strawberry and goodin how about that and
then i got jim litum and my son this
year at the all
at the uh world series but that tyson
gooden and strawberry one that's that's
a classic wait wait how did you get that
i was at the bat awards um uh baseball
assistant team in new york a couple
years ago
and this is an unbelievable story dan we
were you know i go to the bat awards i
was in town for the network and it turns
out there was like
the snow i can't remember what was five
six years ago there was that humongous
snow storm
that hit new york and no one came no one
came to the bat awards but me and like a
couple other people
and they had all these unbelievable
items and i just started bidding on
everything
and uh and that was one of them and then
the other one was this one how about
this one right here
okay this one right this one right here
is unbelievable can you see it
joe dimaggio and marilyn monroe can you
guys see that yeah
yeah joe dimaggio marilyn rowe and two
signed checks
from them and i got that i got that
there too so i'm so grateful
i'm so grateful for that bad event
because i got some unbelievables but
joe dimaggio maryland rose signed checks
are in my house too is that the best
memorabilia you have
i think that the joe dimaggio marilyn
monroe thing might be the best and i
remember there was three guys at the
event
and they were all hovered around bidding
on and i was like i'm getting this thing
i am getting this
i am getting joe dimaggio marilyn monroe
in my house
great to talk to you you must be driving
the wife crazy
all your energy i'm going i'm driving
everybody crazy i'm driving everybody
crazy
my 14 year old daughter i don't know if
you have any my teenage daughters like
all right you're one of the most
annoying human beings alive please
stop talking to me i have three
daughters
and they're in their 20s i've been there
where you're the
you're the you're the dumbest guy on the
planet
i'm so dumb it's unbelievable i'll go
and talk to her she's like oh my gosh
she's so dumb
she plays guitar dan so i've i've been
having my guitar out like you know just
ripping a couple tunes and i'm like hey
let's play a little every rose has his
thorn and sing along she's like oh
you're such a loser
let me let me hear a little bit let me
hear a little bit oh you want to hear
all right this is the only song
this is a shawn casey former baseball
i've never played i've never played
nationally but i'm terrible
uh mlb network analyst wait okay
see there you go
[Music]
here you go dan i changed the court
if rose has his story i don't know i
do the best i can i do the best i can
bro it's just you know that's why my
that's why my daughter thinks i should
get right
because that's all i got oh i gots that
oh it's great to talk to you
all right uh we'll get some baseball
here one of these days thank you sean
great to check in with you
all right dan great talking about i'll
see you guys soon tell your tell your
boys hi too
all right sean casey he's uh in the
cincinnati reds hall of fame